good afternoon on behalf
for inviting me to
but in this conference as the world's
largest international police
organization with 190 member countries
Interpol's role is to enable police
around the world to work together to
Merc to make the world a safer place
cooperation is indeed essential to fight
organized crimes and trafficking and if
there is one area in which working
together makes perfect sense it's
certainly the fight against the illicit
trafficking of cultural goods the
phenomenon so complex and difficult to
combat particularly in times of conflict
as it is the case in Syria and Iraq
so destruction of cultural heritage in
this region has reached alarming levels
that is why it appears clearly that
working together is today even more
essential than ever you can see on this
map then one than the 19 3% of Sharon's
cultural sites are inside areas of
conflict only then can the recently
adopted UN Security Council resolution
aiming to prevent the illicit trade in
Iraqi and Sharon cultural property be
implemented UNESCO and Interpol which
are explicitly called to assist the
Member States in taking appropriate
steps to prevent the spread have
immediately highlighted the necessity of
strong cooperation Interpol secretary
general Jurgen stock underlining the
need for coordinated global response as
well in follow-up to this resolution the
UNESCO director-general Irina Bokova met
in the beginning of March with a
worldwide director of compliance for
sauce bees to inform him about her
initiative to launch a global coalition
of partners involving key stake holders
such as the UN Office of Drugs and Crime
Interpol the UN sanctions committee and
stakeholders from the cultural
preservation and advocate community in
this occasion she stressed that the art
market and the measure auction houses
were a key ally
effectively counter illicit trafficking
why focus on the art market players
because as you can imagine it's very
difficult to protect cut or put property
in situ above all in the areas under
controlled by the Islamic state or other
terrorist groups at the same time we
only have five to ten percent chance to
intercept the objects once they have
been stolen or looted not looted so we
have to act by seeking to narrow markets
for the illicit trade hoping that by
curbing the demand the supply would
eventually decrease and the business
would become less attractive to
traffickers and thieves the
collaboration with auction houses
collectors museums Internet platforms
and various other art market players is
even more needed as there are huge
challenges to face in fighting against
illicit trafficking in cultural goods in
the field in particular for law
enforcement maybe one of the most
important issue is the difficulty to
work in this area due to the very nature
of the trafficking cultural objects are
not inherently illicit which means the
burden of on law enforcement is to prove
their fraudulent origins however the
traceability of an object can be very
complicated to determine starting with
the lack and often total absence of
properly inventories as it is the case
for archaeological objects the absence
of police register containing
information on professional transactions
and artifact descriptions is also a
major issue this tool is not required by
the majority of states which doesn't
allow for the possibility of the objects
the police register must be not only a
register of transactions involved in
cultural goods in the accounting and
initiatives sense of the term as it as
it is the case for United Kingdom or
Belgium
it must also be a register that serves
to trace the good
both and held by at market professionals
and its contents must be determined in
light of this objective listing
different information on the seller and
the object but as I said only a few
states have created an obligation for
art market professionals to keep a
register of this kind for instance in
Europe Greece Italy France however these
registers are considered by the police
and even investigators to be a crucial
tool for preventing the illicit
circulation of cultural goods fellow to
fulfil the obligation to keep an
accurate register would be more evidence
of bad faith we saw that one of the main
tasks of the police consists in proving
the fraudulent origins of an object
determining bad faith on the part of a
dealer for instance is one of the mean
to achieving it so the task of the
police also consists in verifying that
the buyer of at work exercises due
diligence with several criteria that
should be taken into account at the time
of purchase as due diligence is an
element that second vents good friends
good faith among the numerous checks to
be carried out on the object the
consultation of database of stolen
object in particularly particular
Interpol's one and regarding Zoya we are
processing information on 1305 objects
from the Deir Attiya Museum as well as
all known items stolen from other sites
in the framework of this collaboration
with the at maquette players we need to
promote and reward good market behavior
most of museums are art dealers have for
a long time code of ethics or due
diligence guidelines but awareness of
the importance of due diligence still
needs to be recalled to help potential
buyers to increase their level of
vigilance in this perspective UNESCO
signed a green
with measure auction houses and big word
museums under which they agreed to
refrain from buying any Syrian
antiquities that are not supported by
official certificates and proof of
provenance one more challenge for the
police and not the list is obviously the
internet with in particular the
difficulty to effectively monitor all of
these objects offer for sale without the
cooperation with online brokerage sites
it is nearly impossible to counter the
illicit sell of cultural objects through
the internet this is why Interpol UNESCO
an icon of co-signed a letter in 2007
setting out a checklist of basic actions
where the states are encouraged to
cooperate closely with internet sales
platforms some states such Switzerland
or state level institutions such as the
MLA in the UK have concluded interesting
partnerships agreements with brokerage
firms especially with eBay regarding the
situation in Iraq and Syria the eBay
general counsel says his team stays in
close contact with a number of outside
experts and law enforcement agencies to
stop trafficking on the online auction
site by identifying any misuse of ebay
and then take appropriate action to
conclude it is obvious that the key to
fighting the trade in illicit
antiquities lies in cooperation and must
involve representative of the art market
but given the dramatic context in the
Middle East one must wonder if the legal
instruments currently in use to combat
the illicit trafficking of cultural
goods are well-suited to the reality on
the ground and there is some debate
about whether we should better regulate
the market some countries think so as
for instance Germany Germany which plans
to tighten regulation of art and
antiquities trade proposing a new law
allowing only culture
good with an official export license
from the countries of origin to enter
his borders as well in the US where four
congressmen recently reintroduced a bill
into the House of Representatives that
attempts to restrict imports of Cottrell
property illegally traffic traffic from
Syria but such initiatives might be
difficult to implement given the
opposition of the ad market community as
in the US where a political push for the
protection of Syrian antiquities might
be difficult to come by the German
Minister of Culture also expects the
influence the influential antique
dealers Lobby will try to put pressure
on Berlin to abandon its project one can
effectively estimate that new laws are
not needed and that museums collectors
and the market can police themselves in
UK for instance British politicians are
also not lobbying for new legislation
preferring asking for effective
enforcement of existing laws and for
more resources for the Metropolitan
Metropolitan Police art and antiques
squad but as I have said before it's not
only a question of resources but rather
a complexity of investigations in the
field this is why the adoption of
legally binding global measures to
counter the adoption to cantos the
illicit traffic appears essential to
help narrow down trafficking channels
and markets and an advocate are not
necessary opposed to more regulations
thus last month at the international
symposium on the illicit traffic in
cultural property organised by Interpol
the president of the French National
Union of antiques dealers insisted on
the high interest of the police register
as a crucial tool for fighting the
illicit trafficking and that it should
be made mandatory and generalised
in the same way in light of the dramatic
situation we are facing in the Middle
East
we should strongly support the
strengthening of legal frameworks thank
you for your attention